you've not seen anything like this  before the amount of vision and  steadiness of focus Henry and his team  need for something like this it's always  going to be inspiring you have to light  every direction that you see you have to  find a way to get the animators off the  set sometimes use trap doors and we have  to break away the surroundings set a  little bit as well to give the animator  access to the puppet then we go back put  the set back together and then do  another plate pass and another play pass  there's a sense of craftsmanship every  frame looks like a diorama and a  painting at the same time we animated  the branches of the trees starting to  move they have to be animated by hand  whatever it takes to sort of make it  happen